Hi, and welcome to Introduction to Data Science. My name's
Dave, and I'll be the instructor for this course. I've
worked as a data scientist in Silicon Valley, most recently
at a small company called Yub and before that at
a company called TrialPay. I'm formally trained as a physicist,
and I originally became interested in data scientist because I
love the idea of improving the quality of people's lives
or. Building really cool products by using data and mathematics.
In this lesson, we'll discuss data science at a high level.
Together we'll find out what data science is and discuss what skills
are required to be a data scientist. We'll also hear from a
bunch of other data scientists about interesting projects they worked on. And
discuss how data science is being used to solve a bunch
of different problems. This lesson in particular is going to be a
little bit different than the others. We're not going to build as
much. I think it's important to understand data science at high level
before we dive into the details. Alright, well I'm really
excited about this course, so why don't we get started.